Today I found out that the moon isn’t as
old as the Earth and was formed approximately
30–50 million years after the Solar System
based on what is called ‘the giant impact
theory’.
Although no one can say for sure exactly how
our moon came to be, there a few hypothesis
and theories of which the ‘the giant impact
theory’ is the most compelling and widely
accepted.
In this theory, the Earth had no moon until
it was struck by a rogue planet which instantly
vaporized.
The impact is said to have created a cloud
that reached roughly 13,700 miles or 22,000
kilometers high, where it condensed into solid
particles that orbited the Earth.
Over time they aggregated into larger moonlets,
which eventually combined to form the moon
we know today.
This theory is supported by quite a bit of
evidence such as: even though the Earth has
a large iron core and the moon does not, the
moon has exactly the same oxygen isotope composition
as the Earth, unlike other planets formed
in other parts of the Solar System.
This indicates the moon should have been formed
from material in Earth’s neighborhood.
Another significant piece of evidence comes
from the oldest record of Earth’s ocean
tides ever found, which were 3.2-billion-year-old
rocks from South Africa.
Pinstriped circular sand-and-silt layers in
the rocks were deposited by daily, fortnightly
and monthly tidal cycles.
If the moon formed elsewhere, then was captured
intact by Earth’s gravity as some theories
state, the moon’s orbit would have been
extremely elliptical and tidal rock layers
would not have shown such normal cycles.
Computer simulations modeling a giant impact
are consistent with measurements of the angular
momentum of the Earth–Moon system, and the
small size of the lunar core.
They also show that most of the Moon came
from the impactor planet and not from Earth.
The post-impact mixing of the vaporized material
between the forming Earth and Moon could have
equalized their isotopic compositions, but
this again is just speculation.
Bonus Facts:
The rotation of the moon (i.e- the time it
takes to spin once around on its own axis)
takes the same amount of time as the moon
takes to complete one orbit of the Earth,
about 27.3 days.
This means the moon’s rotation is synchronized
in a way that causes the moon to show the
same face to the Earth at all times.
One hemisphere always faces us, while the
other always faces away.
The lunar far side (aka the dark side) has
been photographed only from spacecraft.
The South African rocks indicating tidal patterns
indicate that 3.2 billion years ago, the moon
orbited Earth in perhaps a 20-day month and
was 25-percent closer to Earth than it is
today.
At that time, the Earth would have spun faster,
so there would have been about 550 days in
a year.
Temperature on the moon’s surface is said
to range from 243 degrees Fahrenheit (117
degrees Celsius) for two weeks at a time (the
lunar day lasts about a month), then, for
an equal period, the same spot is in the dark
and cools to about -272 degrees Fahrenheit
(-169 degrees Celsius).
The saying ‘once in a blue moon ‘ refers
to the occurrence of two full moons during
one calendar month.
The Moon is bigger than Pluto.
And at roughly one-fourth the diameter of
Earth, some scientists think the Moon is more
like a planet.
They refer to the Earth-Moon system as a “double
planet.”
Pluto and its moon Charon are also called
a double-planet system by some.
Bye-Bye Moon.
The Moon is actually moving away from us.
Each year, the Moon steals some of Earth’s
rotational energy, and uses it to propel itself
about 3.8 centimeters higher in its orbit.
Researchers say that when it was formed, the
Moon was about 14,000 miles (22,530 kilometers)
from Earth.
It’s now more than 280,000 miles, or 450,000
kilometers away.